hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem subtree of
another tree and this problem is
actually from the blind 75 list that we
haven't really visited in quite a while
because we've solved most of the
problems on this list but you can see
one of the problems one of the few
problems that we missed was subtree of
another tree so let's solve that today
by the way this is a spreadsheet we
created a long time ago basically just
tracking all 75 of the problems in the
blind 75 list you can see i've taken
some of my notes on each of these
problems over here and each of the
problems or at least most of the
problems have a video solution that i
created
and you can see about 16 people are
actually
you know looking at this sheet right now
i assume most of them are viewers of
mine and if you don't really care for
spreadsheets i actually did make a video
playlist of each of the solutions uh we
have about 68 of them done so pretty
much every problem has been solved
except for just a few of them most of
the hard problems at least okay now
let's get back to the problem the
description of the problem is pretty
simple we're given two binary trees one
is called root so this is that entire
tree and the second tree is called sub
root and this is that second tree and
the only thing we want to know is
this sub root this tree this entire tree
is it a sub tree of
this tree on the left is this one a sub
tree of this one now first question what
is a subtree so for for this a root tree
what's a sub tree basically you can
start at any node in the tree and then
take all of the nodes in that subtree
right so for starting at four this is a
subtree of the tree uh starting at one
the node itself is a sub tree this
itself is a subtree this itself is a sub
tree even starting at the root node this
entire tree is a sub tree of itself so
now the first thought that you probably
have is to check if this is a subtree of
this tree let's just brute force it
right and how would that work well
basically we would check visit every
single node in the root tree and then
check starting from here does the tree
match the sub root tree so let's start
at the root right the root of both of
the trees three and four are are the
root values the same well they're not
right so that kind of automatically
means that this entire tree is not equal
to this tree so then we continue right
we check okay starting from here
starting from the four are these two
trees the same well we check the root
value you know they're both the same
they're both four so at this point we're
basically just comparing these trees to
check if they are equal and we can do
that recursively there's actually
another leak code problem called same
tree that i would recommend solving
before this problem if you struggle with
this problem this one is also an easy
problem if you want to check it out but
yeah we can recursively compare these
two subtrees four and four are exactly
the same so now let's check the left
child of both trees one and one are both
the same now let's check the right child
two and two are both the same so yeah
these sub trees
you know this this tree is a sub tree of
this tree because we did find a sub tree
that matches uh this tree so i think
this is one of the problems where the
solution is actually really simple right
for every single node in this tree let's
call it s for every single node in this
tree we compared that sub tree to this
entire tree let's call this tree t so
the way the worst case is going to work
out basically for every position in the
s tree we'd have to end up going through
every single
node in the t tree right so from here
you know let's say this was a four the
worst case would be that we'd compare
all three nodes with all three nodes
here but of course we didn't have to do
that because the root nodes weren't the
same but what i'm getting at is
basically the overall time complexity
for this solution the brute force is
going to be s times t
and yeah this works so basically the
size of both trees multiplied together
so this will get us accepted on leak
code but just because understanding the
solution is simple it doesn't mean
implementing it is simple it's actually
kind of tricky and my suggestion to you
would be since this is a tree problem
most tree problems are easiest to
understand when you think of them
recursively so let's try to do that
initially the problem is we want to know
is t this subtree is it a sub tree of
the entire tree here right is it a
subtree of this tree to determine that
the first thing we did was checked the
first subtree right the root sub tree
that matches this tree right so just
three nodes in this case right and we
found that no this subtree is not the
same as this one right and by the way to
check that comparison we could create a
helper function to do that for us we'll
call it same tree right that'll be a
helper function just to compare two
trees to let us know if they're equal
but in this case it didn't work right so
now we have to continue the problem and
like i said let's think of this
recursively initially we wanted to know
is t a subtree of this entire tree we
found that it's definitely not if we
start at the root so now let's ask the
sub problem is t
a subtree of the left sub tree of the
root node and when i say is it a sub
tree of the left sub-tree over here i'm
not asking is it the same tree i'm
asking is it a sub-tree so we're going
to have two functions in this case one
is the helper function same tree and
another is going to be
another function i don't know what it's
going to be called i think it's just the
the generic function that they give us i
think it's called is subtree so
basically that's how it's going to work
is subtree is initially going to be
called with s and t is t a subtree of s
well we'll check is it the same tree
first right okay it's not the same tree
as s so then we want to know is it a
subtree of the left subtree so what are
we going to do in that case well we're
going to call
the same tree function is it the same
tree as the left sub tree so that's the
main idea but i think it won't make a
hundred percent sense until we actually
jump into the code so let's do that in a
moment but as with most recursive
problems we definitely don't want to
forget about the important edge cases
when we are comparing the trees so first
thing let's start with the helper
function what would happen if both trees
were null in that case are they the same
tree if they're both null and yeah if
both trees are null yes they are the
same what about if two trees like this
one and this one had the same initial
values right like the first three values
we can see are the same but what if one
of the trees had an extra node uh here
right then is this tree the same as this
one of course not right so we'll have to
keep track of that when we do our is
same tree function now what about the is
subtree recursive function if both of
these trees are null is our is subtree
going to return true is t a nulled
subtree a subtree of another null tree
well that's going to depend on our same
tree helper function and it's going to
return true so yes a null sub tree is a
sub tree of another null sub tree but
the more interesting edge case is what
if s was null right s is empty but t is
non-empty in that case is t a sub tree
of this one nope it's not right because
this tree cannot be found anywhere in
the s tree but what if the opposite was
true what if t was an empty tree then is
an empty tree a null tree is it a
sub-tree of a non-empty tree and in this
case the answer is yes and the main
intuition i use is basically you know if
we had a null tree here we could just go
to one of the children of you know one
of the leaf children of the other tree
and technically these have a null sub
tree because they do have a null child
so that's kind of the intuition i use
but that might be a good clarification
question to ask in a real interview but
in leak code's case i think they do want
that to be
true so those are the main topics that i
wanted to go over so now let's actually
jump into the code and see how we can
implement the solution okay so now let's
get into the code and like i said we are
going to define one more function a
helper function same tree which is just
going to pass
in the same parameters right two trees s
and t and then let us know if they are
the same tree so well
let's actually start with this function
because i think it will help us finish
the rest of it so the first base cases
if we are given empty trees right if s
is empty and
t is empty they're both null in that
case what do we want to return well if
they're both empty then they are the
same tree technically so we can go ahead
and return true now if they're not both
empty then we have to actually compare
them so we have to compare them but
technically one of them could still be
empty so let's make sure both of them
are not empty first right so if s and t
are both non-empty and
the values of both of these are the same
right because that's of course how we
determine if two trees are the same if
the values are the same so if s eval is
the same as t val then what are we going
to do are we going to return something
well we know that these two nodes are
the same but we still have to compare
the rest of the sub trees right so we
have to compare the s the left subtree
of s and t and we have to compare the
right subtree of s and t
right so this is a recursive definition
so what we're going to do is call same
tree passing in the sub trees right so s
dot left and t dot left we want to know
the left sub trees are the same but we
also want to know if the right subtrees
are the same so we'll do the same
calculation with both of these and
what's the return value going to be
basically if both of these are uh true
if both of these return true meaning the
left subtree and the right subtree were
the same then we can return that value
so what i'm just going to do is take the
and the conditional and of both of these
and then return that itself so we have
two cases so far if both of the trees
are empty we return true if they're both
non-empty then we actually compare the
trees and the third case uh is basically
if one of the you know if both of these
conditions don't execute and they both
return something so the if statements
will never exit but if neither of them
executes that means at least one of the
trees is empty and one of the trees is
non-empty in that case of course we want
to return false they can't possibly be
the same tree if one of them is empty
and the other is non-empty so basically
we just solved one leak code easy
problem this is its own problem but now
we can use this
function and use it in our real is
subtree function but remember this is
also going to be a recursive function so
let's start with the base cases remember
one of the things we determined is that
the tea tree the one that's the actual a
sub tree if it's empty then of course it
will be a sub tree of the other tree
regardless of whether the other tree is
empty or not so what we can say is if
not t if t is null then we can return
true no matter what right so that's
really simple now what if the opposite
was true do you remember what we said if
s is empty but t is non-empty in that
case we have to return false t cannot be
a subtree of s so in that case we return
false and just so you know the order of
these conditions is very important
because if we did not return with the
first if statement then we pretty much
know that t is non-empty so then here in
this condition i could hear right and t
to indicate that t is non-empty but it's
not necessary i hope you can see why
because we pretty much checked that with
the first condition if t was empty we
would have returned so here we know for
sure it's not empty we don't have to
include this second condition so now at
this point we basically know both of the
trees are not empty so what are we going
to do well we of course want to compare
both of the trees right so let's call
same tree on both of them if they are
equal if both of the trees are the same
then we can return true so let's check
that so is the return value true if it
is then we can go ahead and return true
so pretty straightforward but what if
they are not the same sub tree and this
is kind of the tricky part but it's
simple once you actually see it okay
they're not the same tree but remember
the is sub tree function is recursive so
we can instead compare t to the subtree
of of s right we can compare t to the
left subtree of s and we can also do the
same we can compare t with the right
subtree of s and i don't mean calling
the same tree function i mean
calling the is subtree function so is
subtree
is t a subtree of the left subtree of s
or we could check the opposite case is t
a subtree of the right subtree of s
right so if either of these returns true
then we can return true right because we
only want to know if t is a subtree of
at least one of the trees in s so we can
instead of taking the logic and of both
of these we can take the logic or of
both of these so logic or uh you know
take that condition and then return
whatever it evaluates to so that is the
entire code let's just run it to make
sure that it works so as you can see yes
it does work and it is relatively
efficient even though the time
complexity is the size of both trees
multiplied together so i really hope
this was helpful if it was please like
and subscribe it really supports the
channel a lot consider checking out my
patreon where you can further support
the channel if you would like and
hopefully i'll see you pretty soon
thanks for watching